a woman in the East Valley says her
apartment is unlivable she is desperate
for repairs to be made to her apartment
but she says her calls for help are
falling on deaf ears which is why she
reached out to 8 news now for help smart
lady Victoria Saha has more from the
tide Palms apartments near Fremont and
St Louis
it's hard to sleep in your bed when you
have this right above you but the tenant
who lives here tells me no one from her
apartment has come by to fix it Brittany
Davis has called the tide on Palms
Apartments home for the last three years
but hasn't been able to live here safely
since January when this happened all of
a sudden we hear a big splash all the
plaster up there just came crashing down
to my bed onto the floor it's now March
and that massive hole is still there
this could have been way worse like if I
was in my bed all of that would have
came down on me Davis says there hasn't
been any answers to the multiple work
orders she put in under Nevada law
landlords must fix repairs within 14
days on Thursday Davis received a notice
to pay her rent or get out the issue is
is she's been on the County's rental
assistance program since last year and
has a new application pending we're
giving you our money to live here why
shouldn't we in a safe place to live
it's been so frustrating about all this
the fact that like I work hard just like
any other person paying my taxes and
because I live in a certain Community
like this as you can see
that we're overlooked we went to her
leasing manager to get some answers I'm
sure you're aware her ceiling has caved
in
what's being done typically we don't
speak to Media you would have to reach
out to our corporate office okay but she
says that it's a leasing manner that's
been calling her do you think it's fair
for her to continue paying rent if the
repairs aren't made they wouldn't answer
if they made inspections to any of the
other buildings
Victoria has also reached out to the
owners of the property PGM management
but has not heard back under Clark
County if you have a rental assistance
application pending it prevents an
eviction so long as the tenant files a
response to any eviction notice they
receive and